[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
[音楽]
努力すれば夢はかなう
叶わない人は努力が足りないだけ
以前はそう思っていました
でも
今の私は
努力すれば夢はかなう
とは言えません
夢は叶う人もいれば
叶わない人もいるからです
そんな私の考えを変えた話をしたいと思います
皆さん
ショートトラックという競技は知ってますか
ているっていうかた
どれだけますか
おすごいありがとうございます
ショートトラックは1周100メートルほどの小さなリンクで
ん
4人から8人くらいの人数が一斉に滑り
タイムではなく駆け引きを行って
着順を競う競技です
表情の競輪とも呼ばれています
[拍手]
前から3人目の赤いユニフォームを着たのが私です
[音楽]
[拍手]
こんな感じで協議します
私はこの競技を小学生の頃から始め
中学に入ってからは週3回ここ浜松から愛知県まで練習に通いました
全国大会
ワールドカップ
世界選手権に出場し
夢は
オリンピックに出場することでした
そして2010年
バンクーバーオリンピック日本代表に選ばれました
私の夢がかなった瞬間です
夢にまで見たオリンピック選手になりました
日本を出るまではオリンピック選手っていうだけで周りからチヤホヤされ
自分ってすごいなって思ってました
しかし
選手村に入ると
全員がオリンピック選手です
当たり前ですよね
その中ですごい選手はメダリストでした
私の結果は7位
オリンピックは出るだけじゃダメなんだ
メダルを取らなければ
バンクーバーでメダルが取れなかった私は
新たな夢を
オリンピックのメダリストになることとしました
2014年ソチオリンピック
メダル獲得を目指し挑んだソチオリンピックでしたが
結果は5位
メダル獲得の夢は叶えることができませんでした
悔しい気持ちもありましたが私は現役を引退しました
実は私
このオリンピックで引退するって日決めてました
理由は2つあります
一つ目は年齢です
次を目指せば私は31歳今がピークと感じてました
もしこのソチでメダルが取れなかったらもう次はないだろうな
このまま続けていても伸びる可能性は低いだろうな
4年後自分が活躍するビジョンが見えませんでした
二つ目は
女性として早く結婚して出産して家庭を築きたい思いがありました
スケートのない普通の人生を送ることへの憧れがありました
なので私の予定では
メダルを獲得して気持ちよくに対して結婚して幸せになろうって思ってましたが
叶いませんでした
2014年3月私は一般社員として仕事に復帰しました
入社9年目でしたが毎日スケートだけの日々を送っていたので仕事はほとんどできませ
ん
周りの上司や先輩時には後輩からも仕事を教わりました
そんな日々が続きました
スケートのない日々は新鮮でしたが
私が思っていたものとはどこか違いました
時間がたくさんできて
好きな事して楽しい日々が待っている
そう思っていたのに
何か物足りない
寂しい気持ちがこみ上げていました
何をしても楽しくない気づけば
心にぽっかり穴があき
そんな自分が嫌いになってました
これまで
目標に向かって限界をつくらず走り続けてきたのに
今の私は夢をあきらめ
自分の中に限界をつくってしまった
家庭を持つことは30代でもできるでもスケートは今しかできない
私は再度挑戦する決意をしました
これは私のわがままです
わがままを承知でスケート部の監督に
もう一度スケートがやりたい
復帰させてくださいとお願いしました
しかし
断られてしまいました
関東からは
スケートも会社もそんなに甘くないと言われました
それでも諦めきれず私は何度も監督のもとを訪れ
復帰したい思いを伝えました
その気持ちがあと半年続くようなら考えてみる
それが監督の回答でした
私はこの半年間で
自分自身スケートとしっかり向き合い
気持ちの再確認の意味を込めて地元浜松のクラブのコーチや
大会役員など
スケートを違う角度から見て
スケートが心から好きなこと
夢を追う自信を取り戻しました
2015年4月
スケート米の復帰ですただし条件がつきました
それは
仕事を1日こなし
勤務時間外でトレーニングを行うこと
日本代表に入りんひょんちゃオリンピックでメダル獲得の可能性がある場合のみ
会社としてサポートするとの条件でした
過去の経歴など関係ありません
ゼロからのスタートです
スケートと仕事の両立
仕事面では植生としての責任や新たに役割が課せられ
時間外で行うインフォーマル活動や残業の日々を過ごすようになりました
朝7時半から夕方6時頃まで働き
夜の7時から8時までウエイトトレーニング
8時半から10時まですけど
家に帰るのは11時でした
トレーニング計画を立てても残業で遅くなった日は氷にすら乗れません
時間のない日は自宅でローラーを使用した
自転車トレーニングを行いました
スケート部に在籍していましたが他の選手と一緒に合宿に参加することはできなかった
ので
1人や長野駅
合宿を計画しました
練習相手もいない
タイムを計ってくれる人もいない
ビデオ撮ってくれる人もいない
そんな中で一人で滑りました
宿泊代や交通費
リンクの貸切代は全て実費で支払い
この年の給料と有給はすべて
スケートに費やしました
これまで国や会社のお金を使ってっ
コーチスタッフの方がスケジューリングしてくれて
何もしなくても練習場所があってご飯が出てきて寝る所があって
給与時間があって
選手はただ滑るだけでした
スケートをやることって
こんなに大変だったんだな
経験して初めて知りました
そんな日々を送っていたとき私の耳にスケート関係者からこんな声が聞こえてきました
女性代表には戻れないよピークは過ぎたよね
すごく悔しかったです
確かにこの生活では練習量も足りないし
代表復帰は厳しいかもしれない
体の疲労や精神的広まりん
心が折れそうになりました
仕事がなければもっと練習できるのに
そんな思いもありました
そんな日々を送っていた時
職場のみんなが
私が就業時間後にトレーニングをしていることを気にかけ
私の仕事を手伝ってくれるようになりました
ん
いとちゃん
あとはやっといてあげるから練習行っトイレ
伊藤ちゃんのスケートをまた応援できるのは嬉しいな
がんばろうな
そんな
職場の方の言葉に救われました
この時私は
スケートも仕事も100%で挑もうって決めました
仕事を一生懸命やることで職場の雰囲気が良くなり人間関係が深まること
私が思っていた以上に
職場のみんなは私のことを考えてくれていました
両立すると決めたのは自分
仕事を疎かにしてまでスケート復帰するのは違う
これまでスポーツは
結果を出さなければいけないという意識が強いものでしたが
私の
結果を出さなければは
みんなのために
結果を出したい2
変わっていました
2016年1月
復帰戦の全日本選手権
みんなの思いを胸に
滑りました
結果私は2年間のブランクを乗り越え
総合優勝しましたん
そして日本代表に復帰し
2018年
夢に向かって
3度目のオリンピックに出場しました
が
結果は6位
メダル獲得の夢は叶えることができませんでした
今年の3月私は
2度目の引退をしました
引退はこれで最後です
結局私は復帰しても夢を叶えることができませんでした
しかし復帰したことで
私は
大切な仲間の存在を知ることができました
諦めず努力し
夢を追い続けたことで
私は本来の夢以上のものを手にすることができました
私の中では
メダル以上の価値あるものを得ることができたと感じています
夢に向かって努力したけど叶わなかった
スポーツをしているとどうしても結果が全てと言われ
実際にどんなに内容が良くても負けたら意味がないと評価されます
でも人生においては
夢を追う過程を重視してもいいかと思います
目に見えるものだけが結果とは限りません
目に見えないものであっても一生の
宝物になることもあります
私のように
[拍手]